the first plane load of baby formula
arrived in the u.s from germany today as
the biden administration tries to
resolve a shortage hitting too close to
home for parents all across our country
elise preston has the latest
the u.s military cargo plane carrying 78
thousand pounds of desperately needed
baby formula landed in indianapolis
sunday's operation fly formula flight
from germany was the first of several
expected from europe this week the c-17
brought in 132 pallets of nestle brand
specialty formula it is a large shipment
a very specific and specialized formula
formula for moms and dads who have
children who have allergies where the
regular form formula just simply will
not work the white house is scrambling
to bring relief to parents across the
u.s struggling to find formula the
shortage worsen when the nation's
largest domestic formula manufacturing
plant was shut down in february after a
whistleblower raised safety concerns
federal officials say abbott nutrition's
michigan facility may resume operations
in the coming days but it will take
about two months before product is ready
for delivery at least four babies have
been hospitalized in south carolina
because of complications related to the
shortage these planes that are landing
right now are going to provide some
incremental relief in the coming days
we're going to keep working on it over
the course of weeks and in an effort to
prevent formula price gouging new york
city mayor eric adams declared a state
of emergency on sunday elise preston cbs
news new york